thanks for joining us here at noon I'm
Heather Mills and we do start with some
breaking news here Metro Police
investigating a deadly stabbing just
north of the UNLV campus we've got a
live picture here now so let's go out to
the scene this is Twain and Maryland
Parkway you can see the police tape is
still up now police responded to the
call just before nine they found the
victim with multiple stab wounds already
dead when they arrived
as Oscars began to secure the area in
the scene additional officers responded
to areas where the suspect was last seen
which was southbound from this location
towards Flamingo thankfully at this time
we have a person who we believe is our
suspect detained
and so again that suspect is in custody
the motive though for the stabbing is
not known it is an ongoing investigation